اثنى المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه ناد
برايس على الشراكه الامريكيه مع قطر
معتبرا ان شريك لا غنى عنه واكد برايس في
مؤتمر صحفي ان الدوحه تمثل قوه لتحقيق
الاستقرار والتكامل في المنطقه
قطر شريك لا غنى عنه للولايات المتحده
ونقدر بشده الدور الذي لعبته في مقاربه
نافي افغانستان واستضافت قطر الافراد
الذين غادروا افغانستان منذ انتهاء الوجود
العسكري الامريكي في افغانستان في اغسطس
2021 كما انها شريك قوي للولايات المتحده
وكذلك للعديد من الافغان الذين سعوا لبدء
حياه جديده في الولايات المتحده ودول اخرى
حول العالم
فشراكتنا مع قطر تتجاوز نهجا المشترك تجاه
افغانستان اذ انها تمثل قوه لتحقيق
الاستقرار والتكامل الاوسع عبر المنطقه
ونعمل معا على اولويات ثنائيه واخرى
متعدده الاطراف